[Music]
hello there
oh hey oh watch the road watch the road
i just wanted to tell you a little fun
fact did you know that the guy who
invented cruise control couldn't drive
he had a good excuse
he was blind
this is ralph teeter he was an amazing
guy he lost his sight when he was a kid
but it didn't slow him down
he excelled in school and became a
respected mechanical engineer
he had a talent for visualizing objects
in his mind it led to amazing inventions
such as an early power lawn mower and a
new version of the fishing pole but his
crowning achievement is cruise control
the story goes like this during world
war ii the speed limit was set to 35 to
save on gas and tires
teeter's lawyer was driving him around
and kept having to break to stay at 35
and that constant slowing down and
speeding up started to make our intrepid
inventor feel a little carsick
his blindness made him particularly
sensitive to the motion
an inspiration struck
ralph came up with an idea that we
control the speed of the car without the
driver having to touch the pedals
thus the speedostat was born
obviously that name didn't catch on
in 1958 the first car to use rouse
invention came out
at first it was an 86 luxury feature but
over the years cruise control as it came
to be known has become a standard part
of most cars so the next time that
you're cruising down the road remember
ralph teeter
the genius the engineer
the visionary
[Music]
you